.
AS THEY FALSELY CLAIMED FUSION
WAS ENGAGED IN LEGAL WORK.
HERE WITH REACTION,
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
LET ME READ THIS VERY
SPECIFICALLY.
WE HAVE DURHAM'S TEAM ARGUING A
STRONG INTERSECTION BETWEEN
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, MICHAEL
SUSSMANN, AND THEIR ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP, AND
PROSECUTORS ON DURHAM'S TEAM
ARGUED IN FEDERAL COURT TODAY
ABOUT THIS STRONG INTERSECTION.
AND WHAT IS INTERESTING IS
SUSSMANN'S DEFENSE ATTORNEYS, A
LIGHTNING ROD COME INTRODUCING
ANYTHING ABOUT HIS WORK WOULD BE
PREJUDICIAL TOWARD THEIR CLIENT.
HILLARY CLINTON, DID SHE NOT BY
THAT DIRTY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION DOSSIER, THAT
UNVERIFIABLE DOSSIER USED AS THE
BASIS FOR FOUR FISA
WARRANTS ON CARTER PAGE AND A
DOOR TO DONALD TRUMP?
>> THE WHOLE NARRATIVE THAT
TRUMP COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA IS
BEING REPLACED BY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN, SPREAD DISINFORMATION
ABOUT TRUMP'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
RUSSIA.
FUSION GPS WAS NOT ADVISING THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN ABOUT LIBEL
LAWS, THEY WERE ACTUALLY
SPREADING ARTICLES CLAIMING
TRUMP WAS COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA
AND IT WAS ALL MANUFACTURED AND
MADE UP, SO WHEN SUSSMANN GOES
TO THE FBI AND SAYS I'VE GOT
INFORMATION THAT ALPHA BANK IN
RUSSIA HAS A BACKDOOR CONNECTION
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, WHICH WAS
ALL B.S., THEY ASK HIM, WHY ARE
YOU DOING THIS?
ARE YOU CONNECTED TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN?
HE SAID NO, AND THAT IS WHAT HE
IS IN THE RINGER.
SO HOW DID MUELLER MISS THIS?
HOW DID THE FBI MISSED THIS?
WE NEED A REFUND ON THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
HOW COULD HORWITZ FIND THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS A BUNCH OF GARBAGE?
HOW COULD DURHAM FIND THERE WAS
COLLUSION BETWEEN FUSION GPS AND
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WITH THE
MEDIA TO SMEAR TRUMP AND MUELLER
MISSED ALL OF THIS?
>> Sean: WELL, IT GOES A
LITTLE DEEPER, THOUGH.
REMEMBER, HOROWITZ MADE
REFERRALS AND NOBODY FOLLOWED UP
ON THEM, THE VERY SAME THINGS
OTHER PEOPLE HAD, YOU KNOW,
EARLY MORNING RAIDS ON THEIR
HOME WITH GUNS DRAWN AND EVEN
FAKE NEWS CNN CAMERAS IN SOME
CASES, BUT THE QUESTION HERE YOU
HAVE HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
INFLUENCE OVER THE DNC, THEY
FUNNEL MONEY TO A LAW FORM,
PERKINS COIE, THAT HIRES
FUSION GPS, THAT HIRED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THAT CREATES A SERIES OF
DOCUMENTS NOW KNOWN AS THE
DOSSIER.
THEN THE DOSSIER IS USED.
NOW THE QUESTION IS, IS DURHAM
GETTING TO THE RAW NERVE OR THE
INTERSECTION THAT MATTERS HERE?
AND THAT IS OF THIS WAS ALL
DRUMMED UP BY HILLARY AND ALL
SPREAD OUT BY HER SUPPORTERS.
KNOWING NONE OF IT WAS VERIFIED
OR VERIFIABLE.
IN OTHER WORDS, WAS IT A LIVE
FROM THE BEGINNING, WHO KNEW
WHAT AND WHEN?
WHAT DID THEY KNOW AND WHEN DID
THEY KNOW IT?
>> THAT'S THE ULTIMATE QUESTION.
A CAMPAIGN LAWYER FOR LINDEN,
MR. SUSSMANN, WENT TO THE FBI
WITH A STORY THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS CONNECTED TO
RUSSIAN BANK, THEY ASK HIM ARE
YOU INVOLVED WITH THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN?
HE SAID NO.
SO WHAT DO WE KNOW NOW?
THAT FUSION GPS WAS SPREADING
DISINFORMATION ABOUT
TRUMP-RUSSIA, WE KNOW A LAWYER
FOR THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, WENT
TO THE FBI TO TELL THEM A LIE
ABOUT A CONNECTION BETWEEN TRUMP
AND A BANK IN RUSSIA AND WE KNOW
THE CARTER PAGE WARRANT WAS
ILLEGALLY OBTAINED BECAUSE THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS A BUNCH OF
CRAP, SO HERE'S THE QUESTION,
HOW COULD THE PERSON WHOSE
CAMPAIGN WAS BEING RUN NOT KNOW
ANY OF THIS?
DID HILLARY CLINTON NO THAT HERS
THROUGHOUT THE MEDIA AND TO THE
FBI TO MAKE TRUMP LOOK BAD
REGARDING RUSSIA?
WAS SHE IN ON IT?
AND I HOPE DURHAM KEEPS ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: I THINK MY GUT TELLS
ME YES AND THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
KNEW AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAD NO
PROBLEM BECAUSE THEY FELT THE
ENDS JUSTIFY THE MEANS AND THEY
DIDN'T LIKE DONALD TRUMP THAT
MUCH, AND LOOK WHAT THEY PUT THE
COUNTRY THROUGH HELL OVER
NOTHING BUT A DEBUNKED
CONSPIRACY THEORY HOAX